mes chers collègues ces amendements 14 à
16 d'articles premiers de ce projet de
loi constitue donc la quatrième pierre à
l'entreprise de démolition et de
déconstruction de notre histoire sociale
monsieur ministre pour reprendre une
expression maintenant consacrée par l'un
de vos collègues vous avez donc décidé
de bordéliser de bordéliser un secteur
majeur de notre souveraineté énergétique
c'est un choix
extrêmement lourd et les éléments de
mobilisation ont commencé dès
aujourd'hui auprès de ces personnels qui
ont été décrits avec beaucoup de force
beaucoup de vigueur et et je dirais de
justice de justesse par nos collègues ce
régime de retraite ne date pas d'hier
1859 fondé par les salariés de la
Compagnie parisienne du gaz à partir
d'une caisse de secours et de prévoyance
et il y a eu d'autres entreprises comme
cela qui ont pu créer leur régime au
moment de la création du régime général
des assurances sociales en 1930 puis en
45 certains travailleurs bénéficiant
d'origine de retraite plus protecteurs
ont été reconnus
et il est vrai et il est vrai que le
régime spécial desieg est gravée gravé
monsieur le ministre dans la loi de juin
46 du 22 juin 46 loi fondatrice alors
monsieur le ministre le régime des
retraites des ueg symbolise finalement
une période de chair à notre cœur à
toutes et tous la période de du Conseil
National de la Résistance et des jours
et des jours heureux vous vous y
attaquez ce soir par ces alinéas
monsieur du soft vous allez vous rentrez
dans l'histoire de celle des fossoyeurs
de notre protection sociale
[Musique]